speaking of Joey who called me basic
genoves pasta is my favorite pasta if I
to pick one y if I to pick one over
spaghetti Bales it would be this one I
do like that we've all put a different
type of pasta on here although I am
noticing that's spaghetti I believe I
think that's is that not Linguini that
looks like Linguini that's lingu L
spaghetti come on Joey can't tell the
difference between your Linguini and
your spaghetti what are you doing uh
Linguini is okay but I obviously would
prefer anything else the thing I like
about uh the thing I really really like
about genoves is it geneves as a source
is strong enough that on its own it can
just carry yeah but you can add stuff to
it to make it if you want to you know
fat up a little bit you can add shrimp
to it you can add uh some kind of veg to
it you can add you can add you can add
meat like broccolini or asparagus oh
it's so good it's just so it just Nails
it dude and it's such an intense flavor
and no other Pastor comes close to
tasting like it it's such a unique
flavor for sure yeah uh cuz they they
were just like what if bezel was
everything and we were like all right
let's hear the guy Pesto's goed is go
pesto is god tier I'm a fiend for pesto
I literally went to Genova just to
have just because I was like I love this
food so much I want to go to the source
uh and it was amazing I went to the
source baby SCE of the it was so worth
it I everywhere they had lasagna that
was uh genoves base and it was insane it
was so good it was like H that sounds
like my dream dish it was amazing yeah
just improved on uh genev they had pasta
that was infused with uh geneves uh or
like pesto so that it was like well [__]
I know what I'm getting for dinner
tonight dude I'm telling you like they
it is such an amazing fish and I just
love it uh but I you know what when I go
to a lot of Italian restaurants I
normally I I don't order it all the time
I'm very reserved with how I want to
order it I'm especially in Japan I feel
like they don't do it justice here um
they don't go hard enough with the with
the pesto they they Reserve they hold
back they treat it like it's a Peppa
pepperon Chino or something they they
they do it like a light flavor like no
you got to bury it I respect the
anunciation of that
yeahoo it's like it's a lighter pasture
Japan Japan likes their lighter pastures
and I I feel like Japanese hate their
flavor they just hate flavor right and I
feel like when they do a pesto pasta
here right uh when they just they're too
scared to pile it on I agree yeah bury
it if it doesn't look like this if it
doesn't look this green you haven't put
enough on yeah totally totally they
it'll be like a light green I'm like
what is this spaghetti it's [__]
there always spaghetti here I hate Japan
it's like spinning on the mon Lisa I'm
like why why would you do that the only
spaghetti it's already a work of art
Italians are crying yeah so you go to a
nice you go to a real Italian place here
and they'll be like what kind of pasta
do you want you're like my heroes
they're asking me what kind of fresh
pasta I want I get very passionate about
this cuz I think that spaghetti tells me
you didn't try yeah it tells me you
thought about Pastor as a monolith you
thought about it as all being accessible
from the view of spaghetti and I hate
that uh so yeah all right now I realized
now I'm going to have to put the Tesco
sandwich oh okay I thought we going to
the beans on toes I was going have yeah
do beans on toes first I got to start
defending all right all right defend
whatever the this this picture has done
it as as a bastard you you bastard this
is the worst picture ever as a fellow
Brit okay as a fellow Brit how do you
present beans on toast and not make it
look like the most depressing dish you
so so uh first of all um I I I I
understand that there is a barrier of
Entry to to beans on toast that is
liking beans cuz some people just do not
like beans and I I can understand that
I'm a big bean lover yeah um so the way
that you make beans on I would never eat
it like this the way you make beans on
toast God TI take it to another level
first of all white bread get rid of it
we need we need better bread than this
you can get like like seed bread you get
seated bread you can get brown bread
multi-grain bread you know get bread
with more flavor more starch that
compliments the beans better white bread
gets way too soggy too quick and and
becomes mush so you get the the nicer
bread you toast the bread it's got to be
toast like I know I know but some people
don't do it enough they're too scared
to that raw that is that bread is RA
that's not toasted enough yeah you got
to toast it little there should be a
little bit of the bread that is slightly
like Jarred right then this is where you
take it to the next level put cheddar on
it you you've got to put cheese on it
you put cheese you can slice the cheese
put it on top and then take it to the
next level you put it in the you put it
in the oven right you let the cheese
melt that's that's what everyone who
doesn't eat live in England that's this
is the image people think I never heard
of the cheese so so then you so then you
so bear in mind you toast the bread
independently you get the beans ready
you put it on top you put the cheese
that's not it's just blocks of cheese
right then you put it in the oven the
cheese melts you take it out you fry an
egg so it's a fried egg on top god tier
and then you can put which I like doing
but it's not for everyone you can put
the HP sauce on it which is like a
British staple the brown sauce yeah
brown sauce and then you've got an
absolute gigot chat of a meal sounds
really so good it's cheese egg beans and
bread and it's like a mush I know people
I feel like at this point it's beyond
you can't even call that beans on toast
anymore but that's how you make beans on
toast like that's just like a breakfast
toast it's so [__] I I don't know I
mean I love it you know there's an
aspect of comfort in this I'll admit TR
I mean I I ate [__] you know Hines
beans when I was growing up as well cuz
that was all over Australia but like I'm
not going to argue this because I'm an
American you know so I know the
Americans want to come for me and they
tell that I'm clowning maybe if there
was an American on this podcast this
would be a much more controversial pick
I will say the one Collective memory
everyone has with like you know
unloading a can of beans onto bread is
that doesn't matter how big the bread is
that shit's always falling off that
shit's always spilling over needs to
spill it needs to Spill the ratio needs
to be more Americans are too afraid to
try this they they fear for what they
don't know uh you know they they need
well the one you you said actually
sounds really [__] good dude it's so
good I need to try that now UK for me I
have a bigger problem with uh tusk's
meal deal put that over Greg really well
the Gregs could be up here this is you
know what honestly the Gregs probably
deserves the spot more I'll be I'll be
real with you the Gregs does deserve it
but I had to rep it I had to rep it and
Nostalgia but you know what they've got
to be fair the chicken clo bang chicken
club's good I also like the stuffing
bacon and chicken uh one is really good
too although I overrate I say bacon is
kind of mid but the stuffing is really
good um I I do think that tesos have
gotten way too comfortable jacking up
those prices m it's getting to the point
now where it's no longer kind of worth
it this is pure Nostalgia for me but the
there's not there's nothing better I I
you know I love packed sandwiches I
think there's something about it that is
just so kind of great it's like yeah I
could just Fu Japanese ones I no [__] no
I can just live off bread into some
filling like I feel like uh there's
something about it that just gets me
happy um and I love it I think Greg
should deserve it more though I'll be
real with you yeah that was my biggest
problem where I saw this and I was like
this mother like if we're going on this
route this [__] really thinks a
me Tesco me deal is better than a Greg
if we're in like a matrix simulation you
hand me both your like meal deal or
cheese and onion pasty or sausage and
bean melt I'm like all right give me the
give me the give me the pasties um but I
had to WP it I had to WP it yeah all
right and then bottom middle Fried
Chicken Fried CH just fried chicken in
general Fried Chicken listen I you know
we've gone on about this boneless stuff
I appreciate all fried chicken bone in
boneless it's god um we're being that's
what they want us to distract ourselves
with I like wings a lot but I think
Fried Chicken just takes it for me um
right but even Fried Chicken what kind
of fried chicken just just any Fried
Chicken Korean Fried Chicken's really
good too I like Nashville hot chicken
too it's really nice oh that is good
yeah if you're like all kinds of fried
chicken why did you not order more types
of fried chicken when we were on tour it
was always boneless always always
boneless because it's the Comfort it's
the the true the true gigachad of
realizing Fried Chicken is not of the
flavors of fried chicken the bone and
bone out it's the dips the dips are what
set the the flavors apart and America
does some amazing that's where that's
where you're just like see cuz you're a
fool cuz you don't like drip you don't
like dips drip drip you no drip you have
no drip in America they have figured out
dips that dip game is insane Ranch blue
cheese but you'll go to a they'll be
like Chipotle something you're like I
don't even know you could combine
Chipotle Chick-fil-A sauce Chick-fil-A
sauce like uh I think Chick-fil-A sauce
is great but Chick-fil-A chicken is even
great like without the sauce oh [__] off
man what you serious the sources [__]
great I'm saying it's great I'm saying
like no it's great but the to many times
do I hang out with you guys and you were
just like racing everything based on the
source and I'm just like it's not always
about the source no it is it's not
always about the sauce it really is it
is not no way eat some eat some plain
ass [__] chicken unseasoned chicken
I'm
any honey mustard god tier like smokey
smokey Chipotle god tier natural hot
you're not real Chicken Lovers I I
refuse chicken but the dip is what
elevates it and in my mind Fried Chicken
inhibits that the best uh and I I you
know when we were on tour we had so many
good places single with fried chicken is
more it's more than just the sauce it's
about the coating it's about the
seasoning
Co how crispy it is there's so much to
Fried Chicken beyond the fuing when you
have that perfect piece of chicken as
you cribe and you put some [__] dip
into it yeah yeah it's like you know
when I have if I go to if I go to KFC
right which I don't but if I do and I
have like the LA I'll eat that like raw
and then I'm like all right it's time to
mix it up now it's time for gravy to get
involved you know it's time to make this
better cuz I want I want to mix and
match flavors I want to have more than
one flavor he wants to do a combo
breaker dude let him
combo um um and uh C Sal salad baby I
love a Caesar salad I especially you
know in America it's such a gamble you
either get like the most dog [__] Caesar
salad or you get such a good one and I I
admit sometimes they go too hard with
the SE the dressing and they add too
much stuff that makes it not healthy
when you get the perfect Caesar salad
it's like an Awakening you're like oh my
God it tastes good I feel great and it's
just such a good texture the croutons
with the sauce and a little bit of
shaved Parmesan trees my one criticism
of Caesar salad that I've had in the
past is that sometimes the croutons just
spawn out of nowhere when you take a big
mouth full of it and you just stab your
[__] mouth I prefer smaller in this
picture the croutons are those croutons
are huge I prefer little chunks of
croutons just give me like the little
cubes yeah I love the cubes I know to me
like Caesar salads are like probably my
least favorite salads no the dressing so
good I I love the anchovy sauce so good
it just feels like too heavy you know
sometimes what's your favorite like
vinegarette yeah I love vinegarette
vinett all the if I'm ordering a salad
I'm like making the commitment to order
like because I that means I'm craving
something light you know Caesar salad is
you can have a light Caesar salad not in
America you got yeah but that's why like
I like it I like it in the UK I like it
in Japan it's you know you can you can
and that's why I like when you get to
make it yourself you can apply the
amount of dressing you want I've Rec
come around to like cob salads like I
used to not really like C salads but
like I think I've slowly kind of started
to appreciate cob salads more I love
Caesar as well don't get me it's the
best dressing it's the best number one
baby number one all the way I just wish
some places in America would stop
drowning that [__] in the sauce I love
the sauce but sometimes it's too much
but sometimes you go to a place right
and they homemade they make the the
sauce homemade and it's like so anchovy
and I love that I love it when it's
super fishy the anchovy is good and with
chicken chicken breast like shredded so
God TI what a what a what a [__]
chicken caesar salads yeah they're
pretty
good it's so good I love it all right
all right coffee unmatched and and uh
you know I'm very surprised that you did
not put TI
you know it was going to be on there it
was going to be you know when you said
tiu when I was talking about my I should
have replaced it with a Shortcake I
think tiramisu might be higher for me I
you know what I think it's cuz
ultimately I'm a Savory guy until I die
and I think even though I love tiu
there's I I think the Savory food still
gaps it in my mind yeah that's fair I
just love I love salt and I love Savory
Foods all of these are like very salty
foods generally um and I really like
salt I'm I'm going to die of
stomach cancer probably but I love salt
sodium Overlord I love salt uh I I
there's never an occasion I won't go for
something Savory over something sweet oh
no 100% 100%